PROFESSOR: So we've just
discussed the strategies
for reopening schools
and businesses based
on the indoor safety
guideline for the given
space and the various physical
parameters in that space.
And the new concept we added
was a prevalence of infection.
So we would know, on average,
how many infected people
we might expect in a room.
And as that number goes to
zero, as the pandemic subsides,
we can switch from a
more restricted situation
with an occupancy
N1, prescribed
by the original guideline based
on the indoor reproductive
number, to kind of
increasing occupancy up
to N0, which is the
normal original occupancy,
initially with masks.
And as the prevalence
goes down, we
switch to taking the
masks off and really
returning back to normal.
So I'd like to take this a
little further now and ask,
how would we change our
policies or this discussion
here if we not only
have information
about the prevalence
of infection
but we also have an
understanding of immunity,
which could be acquired
through vaccination
or through previous exposure?
And especially right
now as I'm recording
this lecture in early
2021 and several vaccines
have rolled out
for COVID-19, this
is a topic of great interest.
So let's think
about, how would we
take into account
susceptibility?
So, in some sense, this
was a conservative estimate
of the true risk of
transmission because we've
assumed that everyone who's
uninfected is susceptible.
But, of course, as immunity is
increased in the population,
we're going to have
to modify that.
So instead of having
our populations
of susceptible and
infected persons
being sampled from a two-state
or two-category process,
we can think of
three categories.
There can be--
PI is the probability
that a person is infected,
which means really, again,
that they're infectious
and they can affect
other people.
And this is coming from
the local population that
is entering that indoor space.
And now we're going to add
PS, which is the probability
that a person is susceptible.
And then the third category is
PM, which is the probability
that the person is immune.
And so we have a
three-category process,
so those three
should add up to 1.
So this is 1 minus PI plus PS.
And we can also
further write this
as PVAC, the probability that
a person has been successfully
vaccinated and actually
has acquired immunity,
plus the probability
of previous exposure.
We'll call that PX.
So this would be
vaccination, and this
would be previous exposure
if that previous exposure has
actually led to immunity.
And that's a controversial
topic, still, under research
and may depend on the
specific population at hand.
But let's imagine
that we have subsets
of what these
numbers are and then
we'd like to see how to
adjust our thinking here.
So we're still going
to base our guideline
on saying that the expected
number of transmissions
is the expected number of
infected time susceptible,
so the expected number of pairs,
times the average transmission
rate, average of beta
times tau, the time,
and that that expected
number of transmissions
should be less than
our tolerance epsilon.
So that's still our guideline.
So what we're really
trying to consider,
now, are different assumptions
about this expected number
of infected susceptible
pairs that are in the room.
And we've broken that down
into three risk scenarios.
And let's revisit that, now,
with our three-category model.
So the first risk scenario
was describing a desire
to limit spreading
of the disease
through this indoor space.
This is our original goal.
And by that, we mean, if
an infected person enters
the room, then we would like
to make sure that it's unlikely
that a new case would
emerge from transmission
from that person.
So in that case, we
have I is equal to 1.
And then, now, I is known.
So this is just the
expected value of S.
And the expected value of S,
though, in this new model,
is the number of other people in
the room, n minus 1, times PS.
So you see, now, when I define
my indoor reproductive number
as N minus 1 times
beta tau and I
want to bound that to
be less than epsilon--
that's my typical guideline--
there's this extra factor, PS,
which could be moved
to the other side.
So one way to think about it
is, since PS is less than 1,
we are increasing that
tolerance because there
are fewer susceptible people.
So we're allowed to
stay in the room longer,
have a higher occupancy,
lower ventilation, et cetera.
So this is one case.
The next case is to
limit transmission.
So here we're not
going to assume
that an infected person
actually is there,
but we are going to consider
the possibility that there
is an infected person there.
So that makes transmission
potentially a lot less likely.
And so what we'd
like to do here is
to look at the expected
value of I times S.
And I won't go
through the details.
But for the trinomial
distribution
with three independent
possibilities,
with these
probabilities-- and you're
making N samples from
that distribution--
you can show that the
expected value of this product
is actually N minus
1 times PI times PS,
by very similar
arguments as we have
done for the binomial case.
One way to think about
this is that N minus 1
is the number of permutations
of two people that
can be made in that room.
So if you pick one person
to be first the infected
and the other one to
be the susceptible,
this is the number
of such pairs.
And PI PS is the probability
of each of those instances.
So this is the expected
number of I to S pairs.
And I put a directionality here
because we are distinguishing
each individual person.
So if I take two people,
I am counting differently.
If one is infected, the
other one's susceptible
or the reverse situation since
everyone's a unique individual.
OK, so if we then substitute
into this formula,
then, notice, now, we've
picked up some extra factors.
So now the guideline
would read that RN
will be less than epsilon over
N times PI, which is something
we already had before.
But now there's also a PS.
So that's modified.
And then, finally, our
third risk scenario
was to limit personal risk.
So this is the case
where S is equal to 1.
I'm only worried about
one susceptible person,
and that's me.
And I'm then-- if
S is known, then
we just have the
expected value of I,
which is just N minus 1, all
the other people, times PI.
And if you plug that
into the formula,
then you find that
RN is now bounded
by epsilon divided by PI.
So take into account both
prevalence of infection
and susceptibility, at least to
these somewhat modified bounds.
And let's focus on where
the changes took place.
So first of all, in
the original guideline
for limiting spreading, we can
be a little bit more lenient.
So as there's more
vaccination and more immunity,
we don't need to keep
holding that guideline
at the same level,
even in the most
sort of conservative stance
of trying to limit spreading.
What's more interesting for this
plot here is the middle one.
So now, we again think
up a factor of PS.
But everything else is the same.
So what it means is that,
relative to the calculation
that I showed here,
I should actually
make the very same
plot where I don't just
plot PI in this
axis, but actually
plot PI times PS, where PS
is the probability of being
susceptible, which is
related to vaccination
and previous exposure rates.
So that actually does bring this
down and, hence, make it easier
to make the decision to
relax restrictions and even
ultimately take off the mask,
because as a combination
of these two factors, we're
getting even more safe.
Interestingly, down
here for personal risk,
we don't really care about the
probability of susceptibles
because the only person I
care about in that situation
is myself.
And so I don't have any
effect of susceptibility,
only the effect of infection.